elle redessine en permanence le paysage
urbain mais qui prêtent encore attention
à ces cathédrales tubulaire à ces
silhouettes qui évolue parfois des
hauteurs vertigineuses
une entreprise a bien voulu nous
expliquer cet écosystème son nom bong
l'est c'est l'un des grands opérateurs
du bâtiment dans notre région
[Musique]
de l'apprenti aux patrons en passant par
le commercial le fabricant et même le
bar d'heure on découvre qu'il en faut du
monde pour échafauder un chantier
c'est un boulot de patience ce oui quand
même si on n'a pas la passion c'est pas
la peine le vertige bah on oublie quand
on a amené à travailler en hauteur on
fait travailler sur les aussi aussi bien
pour volant que sur l'échafaudage à
prendre le pouls à crémaillère
on est en train de poser une toile de
verre sur l'isolation afin d'éviter que
le polystyrène masaki sûr en fait
yoann et ses collègues sont des hits et
east des spécialistes de l'isolation
thermique par l'extérieur
pendant des mois ils vont travailler la
faire corps avec cet immeuble pour lui
redonner un peu de chaleur il y en a
beaucoup qui se disent c'est vrai qu'en
voyant faire c'est facile mais c'est
plus compliqué qu'on ne le croit il ya
quand même un travail derrière en fait
entre le moment où on va arriver là il
n'ya pas l'isolation de poser et comme
un nettoyage à l'isolation qui va venir
se coller dessus c'est tout un processus
tout en marron flanc et façades avec
leurs plats thouars il garde un oeil sur
le temps qui passe
on s'adapte quand il fait chaud bas
c'est dur aussi quand il fait froid
c'est dur aussi
mais on s'adapte
mais la vie est belle dans ce village
situé sur le premier plateau du jura
nous avons rendez vous avec une autre
équipe de la société bong l'est dans le
métier on les appelle débardeur ici
c'est de la laine de verre qui est
utilisé pour isoler cette maison des
hivers rigoureux dans le haut jura
les températures sont un peu plus plus
forte ça change
et puis dans le haut doubs c'est pas les
mêmes non en bresse par exemple mais
après les basses est toujours le même
mais après c'est on respecte la fiche
technique du produit selon les régions
comme tous ceux qui travaillent dehors
ils sont courageux seebach d'heure
chacun exécutant une partition que l'on
apprend d'ailleurs souvent sur le
terrain pour parfaire le point c'est
tout j'ai pas de socoa fortement voire
au buste il ya là qui sont touchés tf1
qui travaille et on se sent utile dans
votre métier
oui oui enfin et eloïse pour enfin pour
le ballet des gens violents a été levée
oui j'aime j'aime bien je vous trouve
bien je suis dans mon élément
maintenance et chaque chantier on
découvre de nouveaux produits
et justement en parlant de produits on
apprend sur ce chantier que la laine de
verre par exemple est fabriqué dans
notre région à chalon sur saône une
filière courte dans le bâtiment un
argument de plus pour les commerciaux de
l'entreprise
car si les chantiers existe c'est parce
qu'ils ont réussi à les vendre
et là aussi il en faut du courage dans
un secteur très concurrentiel
[Musique]